foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague George
Campbell we're here for you this hour
AAA
[Music]
825-5225-88-825-5225 we've been called
the root beer float of the Ramsey show a
lot of duets with the Ramsay
personalities and Dave a lot of every
day brings a different duet as I like to
say and so uh so hope you like the
Rupert well the explanation is two
ingredients this is from a fan review
they said two ingredients that are great
on their own but when brought together
are magic yeah I I you know I I didn't
want to go so far as to that big of a
compliment of ourselves but I don't
agree but whatever I think the beverage
we are today but we are here together
and always enjoy being with George we
have a lot of fun and so let me set the
tone own here of course we're gonna take
your money questions George is ready to
go he's got his bomber jacket on I got
my pen brushed his teeth just moments
ago back in the bathroom I ran into him
he's freshly brushed and floss and
George can answer your money questions
and and I'll weigh in but I'm here to
answer any work questions and we talk
about money George you got to think
about work your your income is your
greatest wealth building tool how can
you make more money how can you enjoy
work if you're feeling stuck but I'm in
the baby steps can I move can I pivot
the answer is yes I'll take any work
related questions maybe you're dealing
with a toxic boss or co-worker and you
just hey you know what I just need to be
encouraged can I need to stay the course
we'll take some of those questions and
uh so we're ready to go we've told you
what to expect and uh let's do it Terry
is up first in Tampa Florida Terry how
can we help
well let me hit the button that helps to
get Terry on the line well trying to hit
line two but I trust that Kent knows how
to hit a button so I think we uh it's
all good just a technical difficulty
there you are Terry I'm sorry you're
well you're welcome here on the Ramsey
show what's going on
I was calling because I was wondering if
it is
now what does a woman have to do with
this or a woman in her 20s for that
matter
that's true so the real question is is
it a good time to buy a house and that
time has nothing to do with necessarily
the the uh time in which we live but
what George
your financial situation boom so talk to
us about that what makes you think you
are ready or are not ready
well
I'm ready because I finished paying off
my thirty thousand dollars in student
loan awesome and I have a bit of money
saved for my future future family all of
that
um when I say good time I don't mean due
to the market or anything like that just
as we all know your 20s can kind of be a
little bit of a roller coaster and we
don't know what's to come in a few years
so financially I believe I could buy a
house I just don't know if it's a good
time for me okay so you have no debt now
do you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
yes and then beyond that do you have a
down payment saved
yes how much do you have saved for the
down payment
I have forty five thousand dollars
amazing wow and what's your income
um about 130 to 150 000 it's commission
based
you are incredible what do you do
real estate Wow way to go Terry and
you're renting right now
rent free I've been saying to see my
parents house incredible you've been
doing all the right things and I'm so
proud of you most people that call and
they go like I'm gonna buy a house
they're flat broke and you are the
opposite of that George what time is it
I don't is it game time is that what
you're going with this I want to know
what time it is George it may be time to
buy a house I think it might be now
you're in Tampa I don't know what the
housing situation is there but you're in
real estate so you can easily run the
comps and I'll tell you how to do it the
right way so that you step into this
thing with some peace uh and wisdom and
that is to stick to a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage which is insane in the real
estate world I know but it's going to
allow you to pay off your mortgage in 15
years or less and allow you to still
have money left over to live your life
and invest and do all those things for
your future so if you get a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage where the payment
the mortgage payment is no more than a
quarter of your after-tax income so
after taxes but before your deductibles
Insurance investing you name it let that
be 25 percent
and if you do it that way that might
mean you know I'm you have a great
income what's your take-home pay now
um yeah about great so then we go okay
with a 45 000 down payment and we want
to keep that the mortgage payment at
around twenty five hundred dollars how
much house can we buy and let your
budget dictate your home price versus
what you feel and what you want and that
helps you step into this thing with a
lot of peace and wisdom
and then you can start shopping
that sounds awesome good plan Terry you
are awesome and this is exciting so
again George uh you feel good about that
I feel really good because it has
nothing to do with her being a woman or
her being in her 20s there's men in
their 60s who aren't ready to buy a
house there's women in their 20s who are
absolutely ready so I love it all right
next let's go to Trey and Sacramento
Trey how can we help
I'm doing good thanks for taking my call
you bet what's up we got about two
minutes here so uh get get to the point
we'll try to help you out as quickly as
possible yeah no problem so my side
hustle has actually taken off quicker
than I thought and I'm trying to figure
out when the appropriate time would be
to to get away from my my standard job
and move full time into the uh
entrepreneurial life right what is the
side business
uh digital marketing nice and what do
you uh do for a full-time job and how
much do you make
uh pretty much the same thing and I make
about 25 000 a month okay a month Wow
way to go Trey let's slow clap for trade
today and 25 000 a month that's pretty
good number so here's the short answer
for me and I want George to weigh on and
is on this as well if he has a different
formula the answer to that question when
should you walk from the day job to the
side hustle is when you are making
close to if not the exact same amount
you're making now in your day job and
you have a minimum this is me a minimum
of six months of your income in the side
hustle bank account that is set aside to
pay you that would be the time that's
when we go all right I'm out
George are you there yet what are you
making with the side hustle versus the
full-time job
so this month I'll do about twenty four
thousand oh wow he's right there you're
right there and you're doing that part
time
doing the part time right now hopefully
you can go full time at the end of the
year I should be able to build up that
six months like you can make this much
money it's not like you have twenty four
thousand dollars in expenses
no so you have an astronomical income
compared to your expenses do you have
any debt
uh no debt besides the house how much do
you have in the side hustle bank account
uh about 50 right now yeah so what's
yeah so you're getting there I yeah I
like having six months in there that
just and by the way six months that you
hopefully don't touch because you're at
the point now where you're already
bringing in as much as you're making now
you have very little personal expenses
so I would say you're within
um a couple months of making this happen
I like your timeline with his caliber
I'm like he could leave today and go do
it I think he's gonna be fine but
there's gonna be a lot of cushion there
if he waits a few more months nothing
wrong with that yeah he's gonna have an
astronomical career ahead of him as an
entrepreneur can we talk about Terry and
Trump in my mind super callers is this
gonna be a weird show of unicorns I
don't know but I am impressed they need
to be behind this desk TNT crushing it
they're tearing it up I love it don't go
anywhere he's George Campbell I'm Ken
Coleman and this is the Ramsey Show
oh
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
please
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win with your money your work
and your relationships I'm Ken Coleman
joined by George Campbell and we are
here for you this hour the phone number
to jump in is toll free it is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five and callers are standing by
we'll get to them but first George
um you've got you've got an article in
your hands and I've talked a lot about
this on the Ken Coleman show because
we're helping people win at work
and college grads have got a over
inflated View
of what they could make and should make
and that is that a fair way of saying
that that's a very fair way and you get
some more data on your hands yeah this
is pretty wild as hiring demands
increases from cnbc.com the average
starting salary for the class of 2022 is
projected to be more than 50 000. okay
checks out however current college
students expect to earn twice that a
hundred and three thousand eight hundred
and eighty dollars in their first job
according to one report yeah that's a
problem it is a problem it's not
realistic the Market's not there the
question is and I've not seen any of
these articles that that offer an
opinion as to why I think I have an
opinion but what say you
um I interviewed a bunch of high
schoolers and when I talked to them they
all were like well yeah I'm gonna make
it I'm gonna make six figures when I
graduate and I was like what makes you
think that right there's no reality it's
just kind of this wet finger in the air
and I think I deserve and the the way
things are going with the economy you
need to make a hundred thousand so I'm
just gonna go make a hundred thousand
yeah and so here's what's dangerous
about this and if you were one of these
young people and you're listening and
watch this listen we're not bashing you
right now I don't want you to hear
here's Ken and George the old cranky
guys like the Muppets those two Muppet
guys that sat in the top you know the
balcony
um yeah here's the deal here's here's
why I want you to really do your
homework on what the jobs are offering
what you're going to look at and George
just gave you the number because when
you have unrealistic expectations
George you are going to have unmet
expectations oh and so that starts you
off right out of the gate with a certain
amount of resentment yeah in cynicism
and frustration and everything that
comes with that and so this is
interesting so the number is they're
expected to start at you said it was 55.
well there's expected to start at over
just over 50. oh just over 50 000 I bet
their expectations are that they're
going to be yeah 103 plus and it says 10
years into the careers students
anticipate making more than two hundred
thousand dollars yeah well so they are
way overestimating their starting
salaries one report says by 88 and so
they need to understand what degree am I
after what are the jobs on the other
side of that degree and what do those
jobs pay in my area with my experience
all right so now those are the steps to
take yeah I agree and and so we want to
know okay what does it look like they've
got to know the industry and then more
importantly young people listen go hang
out with women and men who are winning
in your industry
and then say hey if I'm Gonna Make Or if
I if I want to make two hundred thousand
dollars in 10 years what would need to
be true
like let's just get some real coffee and
some real knowledge and so that you have
an idea what what you need to expect now
I want to flip this for a second in my
hands here I've got an article uh I like
that I bring my paper I bring my own
sound effects and uh this is an op-ed uh
uh on Fox news but listen to this
the world is changing as it relates to
college degree and professional success
now George you know this I talk about
this all the time Ad nauseam next to
your desk and it makes me nauseous yeah
it does I talk about it too much I'm
very passionate about it but the level
the leveling of the playing field is
here and it's good for people who don't
have a degree now there are people that
are listening and watching us right now
that they feel stuck because they're
either they don't want to go get another
degree because either they want to Pivot
and they feel like they need that
qualification or they don't want to stay
in the same field that they're in with
the degree they have and they think oh I
need a degree maybe not but here's how
it's changing the headline here is
employers are wising up
between 2007 and 2019 George the sheriff
job postings requiring a four-year
degree Rose more than 60 percent wow
they called it degree inflation
so it was a little bit of a monkey sea
monkey do everybody's doing it we don't
want to be the ones that aren't doing it
and we feel like oh we're going to get
the riffraff we filter the Riff Raff out
because if you don't have a degree
you're not as good as somebody else and
I'm being honest I'm not trying to play
on some populism here well it's kind of
like the credit score it's just an easy
way to go we're too lazy to look into
their finances the credit score tells us
it's a great experience great goal so
that the degree in the credit score have
become somewhat of the same thing it's a
measuring tool but does it actually
matter we know it doesn't you got you
bought a house without a credit score
that's right and we teach this all the
time all right so real quick though
here's what's interesting in 1990 this
is the same time that that we we begin
to see a real difference in prime age
workers who are earning between sixty
and eighty thousand dollars a year all
right so 38 earning between 60 and 80
000 per year a year had a bachelor's
degree
okay today the proportion is 52 percent
so it's about degree degree degree but
listen to this four in ten recent
College grads work in jobs that have not
traditionally required a college degree
and in that case the college graduates
in non-college degree requirement jobs
are earning more than ten thousand
dollars Less in other words the way they
write that's confusing sure
if you have a college degree you're
making over ten thousand dollars less
than your Compadres who have no degree
wow wow so all that to say two questions
that I teach
for our new audience members if you've
never heard me say this before there's
two questions you can ask is a degree
the only way to get the job I want or is
it the best way
now you got to dig but the research is
readily available George it's not a
mystery no and the answer is no either
one here's the great news there's more
and more jobs coming online you have
state governments I didn't mention this
11 states now have removed college
degree requirements for you to get a job
in their executive branch
11 Governors said we're changing it so I
just think this is a trend that's a
great stop it I'm very happy about this
shift and the truth is anecdotally as we
take calls on the show the folks that
have degrees they call in they go I'm
making 40 grand and I'm 100 000 in debt
the folks that don't have degrees they
call in and they go well I'm 19 and I
make 80 grand as a welder and I have no
debt that's right and I go who would you
rather be yeah and guess who's not
desperate for the raise and not
struggling and anxious in their job the
guy who has no debt who's making 80
grand with no college degree so I'm just
tired of this system that's pushed all
of these kids through to focus on a
degree without thinking about what's on
the other side well let's not forget
that we pushed him into this they were
told it was the right way to do it and
then they come out of school
and the debt payments are killing them
they don't feel like they're ever going
to climb out of the hole of the student
loan and then a politician comes along
and they promise that we're going to
wipe away twenty thousand dollars worth
of your loan and they hold on tight
years three years
and then you find out that some judges
wearing black robes said nope can't do
it and they're left holding the bag and
that stinks and so look at look at look
out at the future look at the now and go
wait a second do I need a degree and if
we look at the Technology field alone
George just the Technology field
there are so many what I would call
technology trade schools Bethel Tech
betheltech.net tell them I sent you I
endorse them they have a nine month
program
less than fifteen thousand dollars
George wow and they're starting at 75
000. some are making a hundred thousand
coming out it's a trade school and it's
less than a quarter of the time which
means you have income coming in nine
months later potentially that's right
then let's look at the trades as you
mentioned welders electricians plumbers
Carpenters the field is wide open they
are desperate for people who can come in
and work and you and I were at a
conference recently where uh Malcolm
Gladwell on the stage at our entree
Leadership Summit said that he was
talking to a well-known professor at an
Ivy League school and he said what would
you tell your kids about their future
and then his young kids he said I tell
them to get into trades um that's
powerful this is an ivy Laker you know
an elitist
and uh if you will for people like to
make fun of the point is is he's even
saying the value is not there yeah and
so all that to say this is we have this
conversation because George so many
people make bad financial decisions
under
the guise of well I had to do it
when we've let the degree dictate what
job happens versus letting the job
dictate whether or not we even need a
degree there it is we've got to make
that change and if you want to learn
more about this we explore it in our
documentary called borrowed future it's
completely free on YouTube there's also
a podcast series I hosted around the
same topic and it will open your eyes
watch it with your kids and start the
conversation now also have a great
resource at our website
ramseysolutions.com called debt free
degree it's a great book easy read you
can go to college without the debt we
want you to all right more of your calls
people are lining up don't move quick
break right back with more of the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm kid
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell we're here for you this
hour taking your questions about money
how about work related issues that have
some type of money and relationship
issues around all of that George and I
are here for you triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's stay right
here in our backyard Nashville Tennessee
Jessica is there Jessica how can we help
hi guys so excited to be talking to you
um so I'm toying with my next career
steps and I'm considering possibly going
back to school and I'm not sure where in
my budget that saving would go or come
from okay I just need some help what are
you doing now and what do you want to be
doing
um I'm currently a corporate field
trainer for crumble cookies
and I'm considering going back to school
for accounting because I have a little
bit of a passion for finance I've
started to discover well before you do
that if George and I give you good
advice we'd love for you to drop off a
box uh it wouldn't hurt us that would be
cool I love the crumbles
oh I'm terrible that's terrible but I
couldn't help myself all right so so
you're absolutely certain that
accounting is is the direction but
what's that look like long term for you
if you imagine kind of climbing the
ladder do you want to go higher than an
accounting role
so I'm not absolutely certain I'm just
considering it
um and I before I do anything I just
want to make sure that I have
the money to do it because I don't want
to take out student loans I've never
been in debt and I refuse to be in debt
all right so before we go that step
though I want to make sure that
accounting is the the path so before we
even talk about the money I love that
you're calling us okay I love that but
the Step before we get the money saved
up is do I really want to go into
accounting you know do I what or what
kind of do I want to be a financial
analyst do I want to be a CPA and I
really want you to practice what I call
the proximity principle in fact I'm
going to give you my book it was the
number one best seller and it's and it's
called the proximity principle it
basically says this in order to do what
Jessica wants to do she's got to be
around people that are doing it and in
places where it is happening and this is
if we decide to do it but you can begin
to use the proximity principle to get
around people that are in that field
this is coffees this is lunches
breakfasts hey I want to hang out with
you I don't want to learn more about
what you do the ins the outs The Good
the Bad the Ugly what was the right path
for you and we want to determine do I
need a degree
after we determine is this something I
actually want to do and so if you figure
out is this something I really want to
do because I've talked to people and
I've essentially done a term paper
and my heart has said yes this is
absolutely what I want to do after
talking to people observing them
shadowing them whatever that looks like
and then we go okay do I need a degree
for that to go that path you might need
a certification you might need a degree
but if you do all of that and you go I
absolutely know that I know that I know
I want to go that direction and now we
know we need the degree then we say all
right now I've got a cash flow
okay are you there do you feel like
that's definitely the path
no it makes sense and I am there I have
good so what have they said about the
education path are you going to have to
get a bachelor's to do this the way you
want to do it um the people that I've
been talking to they actually are
I have their masters and from what
they've said their masters have actually
has actually
um
given them quite an income increase but
if where I would start I would start
with Community like a local community
college good and start with Associates
before I went any further ask some of
those folks if there is a precedent or a
practice where companies see potential
in someone like you and they they pay
for your master's degree if you stay
with them I would look into that
yeah that's a great question so what's
it going to cost at the community
college
um I
from looking
and how much money do you have right now
you said you have no debt how much do
you have in the bank
so in the bank I have 38 65. that's
amazing so you could pay for this thing
today without even touching your
emergency fund
um well
my fund is in
but it's in a high yield savings yes but
I'm saying as far as your cash your
liquid cash goes you could pay for this
thing today with no problem because you
were asking about how do I budget for
this you kind of already have
yes so that's kind of what I've been
trying to figure out is like where in my
numbers does that come from outside of
my six months
expenses because I have that I'm not
going to touch that unless there's an
emergency and then I have savings and
I'm using my savings to fund my Roth and
that shows I have more than enough to
Max it out for this year and starting
into next great and then I have an
investment fund like an investment line
item that I'm using to fund a brokerage
account that's going into mutual funds
okay so those are all great things I
would just if you filter this through
the baby steps you've got the emergency
fund let's invest 15 anything beyond
that let's use to throw at this next
goal of getting the degree
so that might mean pausing the
investment in the brokerage account you
may be over 15 do you have an employer
retirement plan
yeah technically I'm doing technically
total I'm 20 because I do 15 of my own
like in my budget and then I do and that
funds my like personal role and then I
do five percent because my company does
a five percent match so I do five
percent match to
um my company's Roth 401k Jessica's just
an overachiever you're crushing it so I
would just dial that back down to 15
let's get school paid for let's get
through this program are you a homeowner
is that a goal for you
no it is a goal for me and the next I'd
like five years or less cool I would get
through school let's get this accounting
job and once we're there you're probably
gonna have a pile of money knowing you
and so you'll be there in no time and it
sounds like you're doing everything the
right way you're wanting to go slow do
Community College then see what you need
don't just get more degrees to get them
like Ken mentioned and see if these
companies will pay for it maybe they'll
start you out with a bachelor's and
you'll work your way up through that
yeah I love that and and you are on your
way so uh Jessica very impressive uh
you're gonna do great things I
absolutely love hearing from a young
person who's looking at it the right way
this whole hour has just been like rock
stars yes very fantastic let's go to
Jose in San Diego California Jose how
can we help
how are you guys doing today it's an
honor to talk to both of you well it's
our honor sir what's going on
well I'm at a crossroad in my life I'm
52 years old my wife is 46 and uh as of
May 1st we are on baby step seven
wow look at you Jose
yeah so my my question is that it's kind
of still surreal two months later you
know not having a home payment is is
surreal and sometimes I I feel like I'm
confused but one of the things that I
need some direction is uh in life
insurance I I still pay on both of us
I just did it for for this whole next
turn so I have a turn for until I'm 62
or 500 000 in my wife like I said it's
46 year olds and I have her to do age 60
of 300 000 and I'm just wondering should
I continue to do that
where are you guys at as far as your net
worth
uh the last time I checked uh which was
around a month ago it was uh 1.7 uh
awesome another Milestone that I just
hit was uh Mall my retirement accounts
and accounts that I have in in
possession in Banks and and all that is
it it just passed 1 million so that's
where I'm at right now that is
incredible I'm so proud of you well if
you you have term Life policies
yes well okay so these are pretty
affordable I imagine
yes between both of us per year it's a
little under a thousand I would just
keep them and until they expire and run
them out until 62 and 60. that gives you
guys another what 10 years and 14 years
and that'll give you some peace of mind
I mean 1.7 million is great but again if
it's if you've got the house and you
know the retirement accounts you could
survive right if something happened to
you God forbid your wife's gonna be okay
no house payment a lot of money in these
retirement accounts that she would
inherit she would be fine
yes that's that's what I was thinking I
just heard sometimes Dave talking about
self-insured so you know I just crossed
that road so I needed some you're
probably you're probably there I just
don't think there's enough there's not
enough going on where I go the thousand
bucks gives me some more peace of mind
for the next you know decade we've
already got the plans in place we're
paying for it we locked in the rate
let's just keep it going and by that
time you're going to be
multi-multi-millionaires and have plenty
of money to be self-insured you you're
doing all the right stuff man I'm so
proud of you guys
well George I got to tell you the
callers we've had in this first hour a
weird hour are high Achievers this is
unbelievable these are all great
problems to have future is very very
bright you all are doing some great
stuff but hey if you don't feel like
you're where they are you can get where
they are we're here to help don't move
more Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win in your life specifically
your money your work and your
relationships a lot of new people
joining us all the time
and if you're new to the program
we've got to get started button for you
because you hear some terminology like
baby steps and one two and three and
four all the way up to baby step seven
and you hear a lot of different things
gazelle intensity and things of that
nature and if you're new we don't want
you to feel like you're trying to figure
out all of the vernacular we want you to
get an idea where you are in the journey
so that the conversations you hear on
the show begin to make sense you can do
that by going to ramseysolutions.com and
click on get started that's
ramsaysolutions.com get started and
we'll get you caught up and get you
plugged in right away Connery is up next
in Salt Lake City how can we help
hey guys it's wonderful to talk to you
today good to talk to you
is should I keep working at my company
just for a scholarship
scholarship to what okay scholarship to
uh undergrad University program a little
bit of context here my I just graduated
with my bachelor's in chemistry and I am
working at an internship in in retail
essentially is what I'm doing and my
wife just got accepted to a nursing
program in the scholarship that is
awarded is for is a full scholarship to
cover her tuition and this is dependent
on FAFSA so right now the scholarship is
good for one year and then I would the
the other contingency is I have to
continue working for the company for a
you could say a lower wage
um sub forty thousand dollars a year
um in order to get her through school
without going further into debt should I
stay in the position or switch over to
the retail side of the company and work
for a lower wage or should I leave and
work for a company making that 50 plus
thousand dollars a year that you guys
are talking about what would it cost if
you paid for this schooling
total value of the schooling
um it's about thirty five hundred
dollars per semester so seven thousand
dollars times four or times two we're
looking at about fourteen fifteen
thousand dollars off the door okay I
would well let me ask another question
if if if if this nursing scholarship
wasn't even on the table with with your
company would you even be calling us
about this question
no of course not so that's why I always
ask that question I want to know where
your head is and uh I think for fourteen
thousand dollars I would take the better
job with better possibilities and I'd
work a second job and she could work a
second job or what you know what I mean
I was just fourteen thousand dollars in
today's economy I think the two of you
putting your heads together could come
up with the Fourteen thousand a lot
quicker than you probably realize and
you're gonna be much happier in the
better job
it's got it so long-winded answer of
saying no I would not stay in the lower
paying job just for the scholarship for
your wife if you can go make 60 and
instead of 38 you're going to just go
pay for that scholarship on your own
anyways and feel more fulfilled instead
of held back and so I don't like these
situations where you're purposefully
limiting your income in order to have a
little you know gain on the other side
it's generally not worth it and in this
case it doesn't sound like it based on
the numbers if it was a hundred thousand
dollar scholarship we may have a
different conversation here
now Connor I thought I heard you
starting to say but a second ago oh no I
just wanted to understand no that's
awesome that was the question
keeping me up at night is the Fourteen
thousand dollars enough to keep me at a
lower wage or should I uh
figure it out another way you know
should I keep networking and using the
other prints now if you just go find
that sixty thousand dollar job it will
kind of solve itself right if you go
find a higher paying job this kind of
thing goes away
okay and you'll get creative and go all
right we're going to figure out how to
pay for this ourselves now you guys got
this I mean this is great so I love it
love it love it let's go to uh Jamie in
Toronto Canada Jamie how can we help
hey guys thanks for having me you bet
what's up
I'm wondering if I should sell my house
uh to pay off debt
what's causing you to go to that kind of
conclusion how much debt do you guys
have
we have 350 000 in bank loans and a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars to
family
whoa you mean bank loans are you talking
about mortgage or is this personal loans
or no lines of credit oh wow this is all
consumer
um kind of yeah it's it's Consumer Debt
where did all this money go towards
um well my wife has been in a surgical
residency for the last five years and um
so that's quite costly and um
I and as a result have not really been
working as much to take care of our
children to get her through her
residency wow so you guys have just been
living on debt to survive while she's in
school
basically yeah basically I um I I'm a
chiropractor myself and she is a uh just
newly graduated uh surgeon I had a
practice going in a different city
and I typically in a different city and
um was doing great there she got into
her residency so we have to I had to
shut down my practice seven years ago
move to a new city started to build
momentum and then you practice and then
we had our first child and our second
child and all the while she's putting in
80 hour weeks and getting through her
surgical residency
wow so why shut down your career versus
you know or hey we're gonna get daycare
so we can keep some income going
sit right with me to put my kids in in
daycare we they they do do some daycare
but the amount of hours that I'm able to
put in like I'm I'm working don't I'm
not not working but it's incredibly
limited and zero focus on being honest
with you guys I'm basically on cruise
control until until now so this is why
this decision is come up I I just told
myself you know I'm going to I'm going
to Coast until
she finishes a residency and I can
finally buckle down and you're gonna go
back and build your practice
how old are the kids
three and four so now all of a sudden
you're fine with them being in daycare
because she's gonna be busy now you're
busy so now you're fine with it
no it's actually the Situation's changed
so she now has a job
um she's on a full-time job back in my
hometown
and so we'll have all the help we need
with family my old practice is still
there and my partner's begging me to
come back oh wow now that changes the
question George so what's the income
today and what do you think it will be
today it's oh my God close to nothing I
make like a thousand dollars a week I
put a thousand dollars a week in my
pocket when it's all said and done and
uh she earns uh she doesn't earn much
right now because she's on a resident's
salary or just you know was and um how
are you guys paying the bills
I'm dead now dead so you're just
compounding the debt problem what will
it be let's go back to Hometown you're
in there with your partner she's got the
new job what do you anticipate that
income being
for 30 a month I don't know I don't
anticipate that off you know day one but
I used to do 30 a month and I think
she'll do closer to 40 or 50 a month
so that kind of allows us to breathe a
little easy is the house back there
no the house is here in Ottawa but I I
have a building in Sudbury in this other
Town
um and um it just came up and one of my
tenants just gave notice for for vacancy
so I'm thinking of moving into the
building all right we got about a minute
left so I want to give it to George here
on what he thinks you need to do yeah
what's what's left on the mortgage and
what's the house worth
150 left 650 it's worth oh man so you
could walk away with what you think
after fees
500. okay I'd sell it today and you
could clear almost all of the debt
if I could clear it all oh 350 and 170.
I mean yeah you're right not all but the
other stuff I'm not worried about
because it's it's uh I've got time on
that I think it's time to be worried I
think what got us here was just going
well I'm not worried about it we'll
figure it out and then compounding debt
and I'm I feel the weight of this and
I'm not even a part of the situation so
I would absolutely I would sell this
house and you might be able to in a
better world clear this debt quickly
with 80 000 a month coming in but right
now the reality is the house is on fire
and you are going into debt every single
week to keep this afloat so I would sell
it ASAP clean this mess up and get
income back in your life no matter what
it takes and this is never an option
ever again oh my goodness I'm glad
they've got a way out and uh so that's
that's good news wow hey great hour
George Campbell I want to thank Kelly
Daniel uh sitting in today for James
Childs and the team behind the glass are
keeping us on the air I want to thank
you America for listening this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studio
this is the Ramsey show where we help
you win in your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
Campbell we are here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five George is our money expert
he's in the saddle ready to go I'll help
you with work related issues you're
dealing with a toxic boss or co-worker
situation uh maybe you just feel stuck
you don't hate your job but you know
there's more should I quit my jobs a
question we get a lot on the Ken Coleman
show we'll take those questions together
because you're working your money are
inextricably tied together so let's go
you ready to go my friend I'm ready
George's got the bomber jacket on if
you're listening to us for your favorite
podcast app or radio station you can't
see him but he's uh he's just all dolled
up we need to start doing a little
clothing segment Ken yeah well our video
audience on YouTube can see they
appreciate it but he's got a great
bombers jacket on he's very very sharp
looking today thank you and uh and we've
been told we are the uh of the Ramsey
personality Duets we are the root beer
float wow and I'd love to know all of
the Duets we need to name them all let's
have the audience do that yes pick your
uh pick your duet and come up I feel
like John deloney's kind of like a
Mountain Dew it's like a code red
situation yeah it's some type of energy
drink that's unhealthy nobody should be
consuming it yeah no no we love them we
love him let's go to Josh in Greensboro
North Carolina Josh how can we help
hey thank you for taking my call my
question is
um should I pay five thousand dollars to
get my Class A commercial driver's
license or pay off my fifteen thousand
dollars in debt first
okay so before we get to the debt thing
I want to jump in here is this is this a
long-term play for you to to get your
your license and drive a truck is that
something you want to do
yes all right and and uh how quickly
would you start driving and then how
much more money would you be making than
you are now
take about 10 weeks to do and
um
I'd probably be making at least ten
thousand dollars more a year okay so
that would help
yes uh all right uh George I just wanted
to know that because I think that plays
into this I I don't think this is
neither or right at the outset that
would be my take but I want George to
dive into this I think this is a both
hand so how much money do you have right
now
um probably about a thousand okay so
we're kind of at this baby step one
getting started and you've got 15 000 in
debt what kind of debt is that
uh about ten thousand dollars in student
loans and five thousand okay in credit
card credit cards okay
and what are you making a month
um roughly
three thousand
could you do extra work overtime side
job side hustles
uh yes okay
because my question is how quickly could
we pay off this debt and then get that
five thousand dollar license covered as
well could you do all of that within a
year
yes okay I'm leaning towards that
because I think if you you know kind of
put the cart before the horse it may
actually slow you down while this
interest accumulates because that credit
card interest is a killer man it's
probably over 20 percent
yes so that tells me we've got to start
knocking away some of this debt to clear
the room to cover this license and do it
with some peace and if you can I think
you can do that quickly because this is
a big goal for you to get this license
isn't it
yes it is which means you're doing
you're willing to do whatever it takes
to get there and if that means you're
working 60 70 hour weeks you're okay
with that you're not scared of work
no I'm not so I would set an aggressive
goal for how quickly we can pay off this
15 000 because that's going to free up
those payments what are your monthly
payments on that debt
um
credit card and totals probably about
250 for minimum and then
uh the student loans I haven't really
looked into that quite yet okay well
we're talking hundreds and hundreds of
dollars a month that would be freed up
that would allow you to then save up
real quick for this license you can cash
flow that at that point
yes how much of the 15 000 in debt is
credit card versus student loans
uh 5 000 in credit cards and ten
thousand in student loan roughly
well how quickly you think you could pay
this off the 15. if you really get after
it how much what do you what do you
think what do you think you can earn in
Greensboro knowing what you can do
probably
to nine months
okay and then three months after that
you could probably scrape together the
five thousand and cash flow this license
yes okay all right I gotta throw
something here Joe I don't mind you
cross it out there I don't know this is
a this is a Choose Your Own Adventure
okay well I mean we understand the
principles I
because he's going to make more money
being a truck driver and he's doing what
he wants to do it gets him in there uh
could you meet me in the middle George
I'll meet you in the middle could he pay
off the 5 000 in credit card because
that's the high high interest and that's
going to free up 250 a month
and and then he gets the license but I
want him doing both I want him take I
want him working the snowball
so here's my theory or here's my
question George he knocks it he holds
off on the CDL until he pays off the
credit card debt that's about five
thousand dollars all right he takes that
250 that he's been doing and he puts
that towards the student loan so he
keeps doing the snowball but I want him
also working the extra hours to come up
with the five uh for the uh CDL license
yeah are you okay with that I would I
wouldn't lose sleep over it that's for
sure but it's not your favorite thing it
wouldn't be my I would the way I'm wired
I go how do I do both and do it in a
shorter time frame to go hey how do I do
this in six months to clean this up and
cash flow this and then I'm willing to
do what it takes knowing the Gap yeah
that's me personally I get it but I
think Josh uh he's again he's not scared
of work I think if he started working 70
hours a week for a short season he's
gonna be able to clean all this up and
get the license is this an instant pay
raise Josh
uh yes it would be that's what I'm
looking at that's a good deal so I'm
looking at then I take the pay raise and
I put all of that between 700 bucks a
month yeah he said it was about ten
thousand more is that what you said Josh
a year
yes at minimum it could be
ten to twenty thousand dollars more well
either way get after it you know the
opportunity is going to be there uh I
like George's route too what we're
talking about is twenty thousand dollars
we need to come up with that's exactly
right twenty thousand dollars gets you
where you want to be in your life you
know what I'm saying Josh yes yeah you
ready to do it are you are you like
ready like you're sick of this you're
done I'm getting out of this I'm moving
forward in my life
yes well get after it my friend he
sounded confident I feel good about it
you know what he sounds like he sounds
convicted he's like that's beyond
confidence he's like yes
yeah that's why I asked him is this what
you really want are you really willing
to do what it takes because some people
go I don't want it that badly I'm not
willing to do like the third job right I
don't want it that badly right he's
saying this is worth it this is where I
want to go and I'm willing to do what it
takes and I like your approach because
what that does is it makes him even more
motivated get inside that truck cab I
get it the carrot is dangling and I want
to stipulate and that's why I left
myself open for some criticism here I
believe the baby steps all the way all
the way through I'm just saying in this
situation it's like instant close if I
can keep going on the baby steps but
also fund an increase in income I'm
gonna try to do that if I can but I like
your plan I think it gets you more
excited it's tomato tomato at this point
yeah there you go or Toyota Toyota thank
you for that that's a deep cut all these
are are only are really I found out from
listeners that I was saying it correctly
it is Toyota based on the actual
Founder's name
that on the commercial break is it
Toyota or Toyota as George says supposed
fantasy listeners of whom we have no
proof hey we'll debate it during the
break don't move this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
show thrilled to have you with us the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and I am looking for our question
of the day here it is uh this is from
neighborly the question of the day
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services with 19 service Brands
Nationwide you can find Reliable help
from great locally owned businesses like
air serve Mr Appliance and dryer vent
wizard all titles that no one will ever
ascribe to me George
there's kid Colvin
wizard Mr Appliance Ken Coleman has
walked into the room never gonna happen
but that's okay George that's why I go
to neighborly.com they'll help out with
just about anything for your home
today's question comes from Gene in
Wisconsin
I've been offered a job that's a
short-term pay cut about 25 percent less
than my current pay for roughly the
first six months but would be very
fruitful in the long run and is in a
field I'm really excited about I'm
hesitant because I don't want to put off
some other goals buying a house wedding
savings Etc should I put my short-term
saving goals for this career change or
wait for the next opportunity once I'm
through my upcoming Life Changes should
I put off the short-term savings to do
this or do I just wait until he's got
this stuff covered and then take the pay
cut that's interesting this is a this is
not as cut and dry as I thought it was
going to be as we started out because
what I don't know there's variables the
buying the house that's easy wait
there's always going to be other great
houses out there I want you in this new
career so this is a little bit of what I
did George in my when I got into
broadcasting I Stacy and I strategically
took a step back
we cut our expenses we sold our home we
knew we were going to take two steps
backwards to go forward and it worked
and it was very strategic we knew it
would work it wasn't some big it wasn't
a pie in the sky
uh so the house I'm not worried about
the web
when Georgia gives me pause because I I
don't know if we're delaying the wedding
that's a little bit tricky uh but I'd
have some conversations about how is
this wedding getting paid for what is
the budget we're trying to set can we
get there even with the pay cut that
would give me a lot of peace to move
forward because I like this plan I would
be willing to take a picture I want to
make sure that spouse or potential
spouse or who I just don't know what's
going on here uh but I would absolutely
do it uh I would take the 25 pay cut for
only two reasons okay it gets me in
on the ladder
and it's the latter that I want to climb
yeah he said I'm really where I want to
be I'm yeah I'm sorry so I'm on the
ladder and I'm jacked to be on the
ladder so that's why I would do this I
wouldn't delay it I'd go ahead and take
this opportunity now and then I would
trust my lifestyle on the wedding I
changed my expenses on the wedding
um and I certainly would relax on the
house until we get that pay bump because
the pay bump is coming that's my hope
it's not very clear it just says would
be very fruitful that sounds confident
that I think it's coming six months
later there's a pay bump but you know
there's a lot of false promises with
some companies and careers where they go
oh well within six months you'll
probably get a raise and it'll probably
get promoted so I hope it's a sure thing
yeah thank you so much for the question
all right let's get to Kaden who joins
us now in Orlando Florida Caden how can
we help
yes I get paid in cash app for my side
gigs I was wondering if this is a bad
idea
well it'll be a bad idea what kind of
business is this
uh I do cattle I prep cattle for Shell
kind of like uh the tape crew and the
Nascar race no kidding great explanation
because you answered my next question I
was like what does that mean to prep
cattle I knew what it was I knew Ken
didn't and so I'm glad he clarified Ah
that's great so you like you're brushing
the cows getting them looking all shiny
and neat
yeah pretty much yep they put glue and
paint in them as well and who's paying
you
the the client whoever wants that
service completed
um to their cattle at that show
um yeah you're asking them hey can you
pay me on cash app and they say okay
yep
so you called us because you have some
type of a concern I'm guessing yes
yes in terms of investing
well what's that have to do hold on a
second what does that have to do with
the cash app oh are you investing in the
cash app
as well
I would just not invest in the cash app
I would use it as a payment platform not
as an investment platform so Ken for
those that listeners and for you I don't
even know so in the cash app they've
become kind of an investing platforms
where you can invest in single stocks
and crypto and all these different
things through the cash app as well as
using it to pay sure peer-to-peer right
and so I would not mix the two things
together and if that is something that
is that you're tempted by I would maybe
switch to like a venmo
okay and strictly use it as a payment
platform and as far as it being a bad
idea it's fine I mean I pay my
Landscaping guy through venmo and I
assume that he's reporting all the
income as a business account on his
taxes so it would be a bad idea if this
was fraud and you weren't reporting the
income but other than that it's fine
it's just another payment platform
yeah the biggest thing was just you know
be investing is it is it a wise thing to
do you're getting 500 bucks and then
cash app is like hey you got 500 bucks
you should invest in some single stocks
right now
right is that kind of the idea
yeah
um but more so
you know a little lit you know maybe
doing just like a little bit of
investing and not sitting there and
investing the 500 just exactly little by
little and best thing as I go through
and I grow through my life to where you
know when retirement comes around and I
would immediately transfer that income
to your bank account to a checking
account and then invest from the
checking account through a different
platform something more legitimate May
if you're doing an IRA on your own you
can do it through Vanguard Fidelity
Schwab I don't really like these kind of
little investing apps that cause you to
make bad decisions because they're
giving you notifications yeah
I feel like it's a slot machine it has
that sitting there and you're just I'm
just hitting the button I'm hitting the
button and all of a sudden but someone's
reloading your card that's right income
from your job yeah I I I like that
advice let's go to Jacob in Oklahoma
City Jacob how can we help
well um I'm wanting to know what the
best method of taking you is uh Jacob I
think you just took your phone and put
it under your armpit can you can you
pull it back up close to your ear
I'm wanting to know what the best method
is to save money to to buy a sailboat
because I don't I don't want to buy I
want to I don't want to borrow a loan
okay cool what's your financial
situation are you debt-free do you have
an emergency fund do you have savings
but checking account I don't have a
savings account and I'm debt free I am
currently employed and I don't I don't
know what the best method is to save
money because I thought about putting it
in a mutual fund or putting in a bank
account or putting it in a store of
savings such as precious metals but I
don't I don't know what the best method
of saving money is I sure I sure though
don't want to borrow a loan good well
I'm glad you don't want to borrow a loan
I would put this in something better
than precious metals or a mutual fund
because how far away is this goal do you
want to buy this boat in the next year
or two or is this 10 years
uh between between five to seven years
okay
my personal preference would just to be
to put this in a high yield savings
account online uh it'll help it'll keep
it safe it's FDIC insured up to 250 000
per account category and that will let
your money grow at right now about four
percent or so which is fine the goal
here is not to double your money for the
sailboat that you're gonna you're more
likely to lose your money than you are
to double it if you start to play that
game so I would just put in a high yield
savings account and start to set an
aggressive goal and say hey they sell
how much the sailboat cost
okay so will a high-yield savings
account protect my money from uh
inflation because I remember in 2020
inflation was like 10 or something
inflation you're going to be about
matching inflation right now with these
high-yield savings accounts I would not
worry about inflation your savings rate
is way more important than the inflation
rate
so I would just set a goal don't worry
about it stop watching the headlines
don't put it in Precious Metals just put
it in a savings account and make sure
you're debt free I don't want you to
have a paid for home before you go out
and buy a toy like a sailboat but it's a
great dream Jacob I got 10 seconds give
me a sale turn a sailboat term that I
can use with George what would it be
um enough room oh very good George give
me enough room to get into this
commercial break back away please well
done don't want I don't even know what
that means I didn't have time to ask you
we'll Google it yeah we'll Google it
this is a Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague the
esteemed the incomparable
George Campbell that was pretty good do
you like that yeah yeah I tried to
hanging out with Ken I mean it's just
it's dopamine on steroids there it is uh
speaking of dopamine we got your
dopamine we'll give you some hope
that'll give you the hit of some
dopamine hope I mean Kelly Kelly Daniel
I like that one she actually did like
Kelly's a taste maker and if she gives
you the oh I think I transcended dad
joke on that one she actually well you
can't see in the control room she
actually toasted George with her uh tea
or coffee whatever she's enjoying right
now uh she sits into now the esteemed
and uh incomparable James Childs or our
fearless leader that's right he was
doing some Ministry time right now I
just want to let the audience know
Ministry time or shuffleboard in Boca no
it's a legitimate Ministry time oh okay
very good he's a good man good man a
good husband I'll tell you who else were
excited to talk to today is Sarah who
joins us on the line in Chicago Sarah
how can we help
thanks for taking my call you bet what's
going on Sarah awesome my husband and I
are on baby step three and cannot get
out uh wondering if husband should stay
home to get really radical with the baby
steps to just start stacking cash and
Propel us for it whoa wow
a two-year-old and a five-year-old okay
and and and and how would he staying at
home allow you guys to make progress
explain the numbers
Child Care here in the Chicago area for
three kids is four thousand six hundred
dollars okay a month holy smokes
um yes for two kids because my oldest is
going to public school in August for two
kids because of their ages and also
um every year they increase tuition
which is always expected it goes to
three thousand seven hundred a month so
there's only a 900 savings
um we make 260
000 as a household I make a hundred and
seventy thousand and my husband makes
ninety thousand so when you look at the
take home I take home after taxes and
health insurance which is on mine my
take home
um would be eight thousand three hundred
and my husband's take home uh with taxes
because we're dual income family is four
thousand eight hundred so he's pretty
much paying the daycare bills and we
just have no margin if something comes
up
um whatever it might be we've built up
but you said three so many times we've
been almost done it two years we paid
off 105 000 in debt in 14 months wow one
kid we got after it big time we cashed
out stocks sold the car like got rid of
leases we went really at it
um but we just can't Propel Ford because
you know we had more kids we've moved
we've propelled our careers but we can't
get ahead so we're looking for something
to unlock us but will the margin but
will the margin be there yes I
understand that the expense goes away
but you're still at the you're still at
the same 8300
yeah no it's a great a point so looking
at um the every dollar app which we love
and we've been through FPU with my take
home of 8 300.
um it gives us still less to budget
after doing house and insurance because
all our health insurance Etc it would
give us about two thousand two hundred
dollars less to budget so we would try
to
um maneuver that to be I'm confused
though because his take-home pay is
still more than you're paying for
daycare so how do you end up with more
money if he stays home
um well I think we also look at cutting
different
um budgets and different things just to
get to get radical because we also have
to pay for
um sorry after school care as well so
why not um oh you're saying there's
other expenses
I still think you're gonna net I mean
I'm looking at the numbers here you're
paying 44 in take-home pay towards
daycare he's making 57 and take home pay
oh no he's making 4 800 and take home
pay I understand 57 000 a year is what
he's bringing home and you're paying in
daycare 44 000 a year if it goes down to
3 700 a month
right but that's 900 George just you you
share it but there's nine hundred
dollars right there
right okay I think that's why that's
what you like which we've been trying
like cash flow is very challenging for
us we've been trying we've been trying
to like get ahead it just seems like
something always kind of comes up I
think there's other expense your daycare
is astronomical don't get me wrong yeah
but you guys are taking home
over thirteen thousand dollars a month
we are so where is the other nine
thousand dollars going
yes I'm looking at the
um the house is 4 500 because our rent's
2400 and then to keep the house
operating it's about four thousand five
hundred
um we have gas I'm in sales so I travel
for work
um and then I mean we've had to
um you know I think our discretion got a
little out of hand so we carried that
back
we've had some travel we had a parent
death
um in the family we've had two babies
we've had a ton of medical
um just because we were paying offset we
didn't go in stork mode so we're we're
just behind we're trying to figure out
the debt is gone life has hit you but
now we're looking ahead and we're going
all right the debt is gone life's not
always going to be this chaotic we're
not always going to be in daycare but
just look at the numbers the first place
I would cut is not his entire income the
first place I'd cut is everything else
in the budget including the
discretionary spending I I have a
suggestion Sarah that I want you to be
open-minded to okay yeah
okay great and this is from our
experience from Stacy and I's experience
when the kids were younger my kids are
teenagers now but when they were younger
I was here at Ramsey
and Stacy was working full-time and we
needed someone to be there so they were
in school but we needed someone to be
there when they got home from school
around 2 30 until around 5 36 so that
the kids were doing their homework and
and then you know so we we looked at
that and we found a a nice lady we
looked for a lot for I don't know I'd
say a long time I'd say four or five
months we found the right person
and it was a retired lady she's a
grandmother and so she was a fraction of
what it was going to cost us to use a
service
and I would just consider that if I were
you if your husband kept his income and
let's say uh because you're already
going to pay for after school care
anyway
so what if for the two Littles that are
not going to be in school in the fall
you find a grandmother somebody that you
met through a church or a neighbor
somebody in there did you check them all
in care.com and find a part-time Nanny
yeah but just what if we did that and
they were in your home they were being
cared for the person did laundry you
know they help with meal planning
majorly what's that I said preach yeah
that would be amazing but but you have
to look into that this is not like
something that I've just crafted in in
my head right this is possible and so
let's just say that that person George
do some math for me if you pay them an
hourly rate of 15 20 an hour I don't
know what that would be but depending on
the 2020 for Chicago area I imagine 20
to 25 because we did look at nannies
that may not work it may not work out
but the point is is if you figure out a
way some of the hours you just gotta
find a way I don't think him coming home
is the right move here this is something
he wants okay
open to it we just are trying to get
ahead I think we're used to be working
more not less yeah I think he actually
needs to work too I think you but I
think he needs to work a second job
maybe for three months six months a year
truthfully the house payment if you if
it's just your income the house is just
too much at that point so if you lose
this income the numbers get skewed in a
bad way and so I would keep the income
and I'd find every other place to cut
because it sounds like truthfully
there's probably some other things we
could cut first and this just feels like
a nice shortcut to hopefully fix things
but My worry is he stays home nothing is
fixed it's still chaotic because the
numbers didn't really change
right right
um no that's fair thank you we're just
looking at all sorts of options so you
guys remember my first phone call when I
got through listen go find your Mrs
Doubtfire I think that's the play I
really do I really appreciate it I think
the number's going to be in your favor
but run the numbers crunch the numbers
based on your market and we'll see
George but I I like that move they're
not in the daycare system they're in
their home that person can also do some
things around the house you heard how
she was like oh that'd be nice yeah
imagine if they're doing laundry helping
with meal planning the daycare struggle
is real it is especially in these high
schools you don't get any of those home
benefits they don't do your laundry
they're not doing meal planning that'd
be nice they're just chalking your kids
full of gummies and what do you call
those goldfish those cheddar cheese
snacks that you love so much George
you're gonna be a dad it's going to be
here soon I'm dreaming about it oh this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George Campbell
and he's wearing a fantastic bombers
jacket here so if you don't watch the
show thank you Ken you want to tune into
that some of the smaller gentlemen out
there they can see what he's wearing and
you can pull those off that's my target
demo for the small dudes out there I got
you covered let's go to Christian in
Atlanta Georgia Christian how can we
help
hey guys how are you doing today we're
having a blast what's going on yeah it
sounds like you're having a fun time uh
my wife and I are in a very uh unique
opportunity where our name is up we're
next on the wait list for our community
to rent out our house
um and it's we only have three months to
rent it out once our name comes up and
it could be tomorrow or it could be two
years from now and we're wondering um
your opinion on renting it out versus uh
just sticking where we are we're on baby
step six already so we could just keep
paying down the mortgage and um be out
of debt in probably I've got a couple
questions this sounds is this like a
real hot neighborhood to the point that
they've got this kind of process where
it's almost like a lottery where it's
like this is your chance and then wait
list there's a wait list just to be able
to rent your home
where is this in Atlanta do you mind
telling me
uh yeah we're in Dunwoody oh that
explains it right there in the circle
okay yep um so you're getting a little
Starry eye going we could rent this
place what can you what four grand a
month yeah well that's what I'm asking
what's the rent what could you get
what's the going rate what do you think
you'll get
um yeah realistically we could get
between 5000 and 5500 a month
um and our our mortgage payment is about
2600 a month oh I'm so excited to have
George answer this George this is I want
to know what you're going to say I'm
such a Debbie Downer Dream Crusher go
ahead I may have questions well what
you're going to do is you're going to
have to go buy a super expensive house
and get another mortgage which we don't
want you and then hope that you know the
idea no sense is that the renter they're
paying the mortgage for us and
everything's gonna work out perfectly
what if he rented somewhere else George
well I don't think you guys are gonna go
rent somewhere else my guess is you're
going to want to go buy another house
yeah we have a six month old kid and
part of this is a we're currently in a
townhouse and we bike a yard
um and so that's part of the motivation
six month old needs to run around Ken
and he's wrong
he just he just I'm Justin I'm having
some fun with this too because here's
the deal even if he didn't have the kid
and you didn't want the yard and you
wouldn't rent in Dunwoody in that area
is very pricey so this is again you're
not making any progress financially at
least that's the way I see it George I
run a single family home with a yard in
your area what would that cost
what's the home value I would probably
be between 5 and 700k and I assume you
guys don't have a down payment you'd
have to do some kind of HELOC situation
cash out refi to get some money to even
put down on this house
um no we could we could get 130k we've
got about 90k cash and about 60k in um
Investments right now 130k on a 700 000
house it still leaves you with almost
600 000 mortgage yeah
it just feels like it feels good to get
the rent money because it's higher than
our mortgage but you're also gonna then
absorb a huge mortgage on the other side
which is going to stress you guys out
and lose the home you're in I just if
personally I would get excited about it
for about 10 minutes and I talk it over
my wife and we'd be like yeah we're just
not going to do it it sucks but we're
just not at that place where it makes
sense
yeah even though the interest rates it's
like 265 and it just seems like such a
like a once in a lifetime opportunity
yeah you're going to get a 600 000
mortgage with a six percent interest
rate going oh my gosh our mortgage is
now six thousand dollars a month it's
not worth the spread that we were making
on our on our rental mortgage rates are
more than six right now they're over
seven am I right George yeah on the 30
year old 30 yeah absolutely the 15's not
even worth it here's the deal here's
what you're doing it's not worth it but
here's I want you to see what you're
doing
uh because it's very normal Christian
you're getting hung up on the interest
rate that you have now you're called
that's such a good deal but you're
looking at one number you're not looking
at all the numbers and what George and I
have attempted to do here is walk you
through all of the numbers
that makes sense yeah and I have I have
crunched some numbers on like
opportunity cost and um all of the other
the other things that the other expenses
that could go into it but
um there's also the the through to the
question yeah yeah it certainly opens us
up to more risk and you know the thing
needs a new roof for a new HVAC and then
your how new house needs a new HVAC and
now you're all of a sudden going this
was a bad plan and I assume you guys
have an amazing income it sounds like
you're doing so great financially that
you don't really need this rental income
it's not going to change your life
that's true yeah I think thankfully to
um to my parents who are huge fans of of
the the Ramsey program
um my wife and I have really good
financial habits and we actually just
crossed over the million dollar mark
less than a month ago amazing oh wow
congratulations you're already there
yeah don't do this my friend thank you
very much don't get sucked into the
Matrix okay the way I would do it and
it's old school and it works and it's
slow I would pay off my primary
residence and then stack up cash and buy
a rental or find a deal and do it the
right way yeah good man Christian you're
crushing it yeah wow let's go to Wyatt
now in the windy city George Chicago
Illinois Wyatt how can we help
Kevin George how's it going guys well
we're having a blast how are you doing
I'm doing fantastic thanks for taking my
call
um so I'd just like to start off by
saying I started listening five or six
months ago and in two weeks I'll pay off
the rest of my student loan debt and
then cash flow my senior year so thank
you guys congratulations give us the
numbers on that so people can hear that
it's it can be done how much did you pay
off
all right well 50 I will in two weeks so
I need two paychecks to do it but in two
weeks I will finish paying off 5700 in
student loans
um and then I'll be able to cash flow
the senior year basically just because I
chose to stay in state and living from
home good for you man um thank you guys
yeah so I appreciate that but I'm
calling today because
of my mom and she's 53 and she has a 72
000 HELOC and it's my opinion that she
needs to go to Valentine's because she
doesn't have any retirement and I'm
starting to worry about her then I'm
gonna have to take care of her
so my question is for you guys how can I
ask my mom's son get her on board the
baby steps and the baby rooms and
cleaning hmm
this is the age-old question how do I
get someone else to do something that
they don't want to do
well yep she uh I don't think she likes
being in bed and she's starting to form
a plan but I don't think she realizes
the situation that she's in and how bad
it is has she watched any of the show or
listened to maybe a podcast is that
something that she would do in her
normal rhythm
not necessarily in a normal Rhythm I
have shared
um one in one hour of the episodes from
from Spotify I'm not sure if she
listened or not yeah but she is someone
who is willing to learn and grow how
often do you see your mom
[Music]
for the summer I lived from
Massachusetts so I'll be I'll be living
with her when I'm when I begin a fall
semester so okay and be with her every
day starting in September cool well what
if
you watched FPU with her you took her
through Financial Peace University said
hey Mom I'm gonna pay for this here's
all I'm asking you to do I'm gonna come
over we're gonna have dinner once a week
and I want to just watch another lesson
with you we'll just have a conversation
about it and see what you think would
she be willing to do that
yeah I think she would be willing to do
that definitely and I think if you come
out with empathy because I know what
it's you know when you're a son going to
his mom giving her financial advice it
just feels weird because she's like I
still remember when I change your diaper
dude and you're trying to tell me how to
live my life and so there's gonna be a
bit of that and so I think the more you
come at it with empathy the more you
reveal her own pain to her in a way that
isn't judgmental but it is out of love
and you go Mom listen listen what your
retirement looks like if you keep this
up I don't want that for you
and as much as I love you I don't want
to be taking care of you in your old age
because you didn't take care of your own
finances I want you to have the great
retirement where you're not reliant on
me
and if you do all of that with a spirit
to teach a spirit to love her well I
think she'll turn around and it may be
longer than you want it to and she's at
53 it's harder to change those habits
that she's had for many many years right
and there's a lot of unveiling she needs
to do which is why Financial Peace
University is so great because you go Oh
I thought the HELOC was the solution
turns out it was a terrible shortcut
so I'm gonna gift you Financial Peace
University to go through that with your
mom and I hope that that turns her
around of course encourage her to listen
to the show the podcast give her the
Total Money Makeover try it all she may
be a book person versus a video person
try it all and see if we can get her on
board so hang on the line Skyler's gonna
pick up we'll gift you one year
Financial Peace University appreciate
you calling in congrats on the success
well done George always good to be with
you my friend you too thanks to Kelly
Daniel for steering the ship this hour
thanks to you America this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show so we help you win in life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships all three of those
areas are tied together I'm Ken Coleman
George Campbell joins me this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five so we're taking your calls
money questions how about work questions
George is the money expert I'll help you
in your work life
and that could be I'm stuck I'm in a
toxic situation I'm burned out I'm bored
I want to make more money
any of those questions we want to help
you increase that income that gets you
through the baby steps faster so I'm
here to help in that area and George of
course is the uh I mean he's he's the
Mack Daddy wow the daddy of the Mac I
think they said
it is I don't remember what artist said
that I was probably four years old so I
have no idea yeah there it is there it
is I have to do that on Ask Jeeves to
figure out who who did that one I Do I
Do
888-825-5225 is the number to jump in
George and I love doing this so we're
gonna start it out this hour with Nick
in the Big Apple Nick how can we help
hey good afternoon guys thanks for
taking my call you bet what's up
so
um I make a lot of money I've been with
the same job for about four years I'm 26
years old
but I recently this past year uh have
just been struggling with some mental
health issues
uh everything at work seems to be
negative I contribute a lot I feel like
I'm doing my job well but the
organization itself is not doing all
that well but all the negativity really
trickles down it's a lot of yelling it's
a lot of nothing's ever right hold on
hold on a second who's yelling
a lot of the leadership team
okay and and what else is going on I
heard that you you feel like you're
doing your job you're pulling your
weight you've got some teammates that
aren't or maybe your leader isn't what's
going on there
right exactly so I work in Enterprise
technology sales B2B and
it can be interesting the way that some
of these
um
deals Shape Up and sometimes you'll have
years where it'll be very dependent on
one or two transactions so you're
basically All or Nothing
um and I've had a good run so far but
it's it's spotty there's things that you
can't control you could be really good
at your job but your attainment might
not reflect that sure um and I think
that's what's going on across the
organization and especially the economy
the way that it is
um it's it's been challenging this past
year especially so what does it mean to
you when you say I'm having mental
health issues what does that look like
feel like
um just every day that I wake up
during the work week it's another day
that I just would rather not mutter
through and just kind of going through
the motions losing motivation yeah
um really just
struggling to keep my performance where
it was because I just don't feel valued
I don't feel like that's it I make any
sort of difference you nailed it all
right so the reason I asked this and I
don't I want us to be careful
um and and Nick this is not at you this
is this is to the larger audience as
well
um
I guess you could get into a debate
about whether that's mental health or
not I don't think that's what I would
call a mental health issue that right
there is just you aren't feeling valued
and you don't want to keep going into
that place and yet you got to right now
until you replace it and so there's
obligation
that is colliding with you know
exhaustion I would tell you you are
mentally and emotionally exhausted that
I know and and and so it's okay to use
the phrase mental health but I just want
to stipulate that you're okay
you just need a new location
uh you need a new gig
and so I don't know if you were calling
for permission on that you don't need it
from us but I think I'm looking if you
haven't already started looking I'm
looking because when I hear things like
they're yelling and it's just a nasty
culture that is rarely able I mean
rarely can you change that you having a
meeting with your leaders probably not
going to change that is that right
yeah that's correct um I am asking for
your permission now because I'm it's
tied to a financial predicament what's
the predicament
the predicament is I am under contract
to purchase a co-op
in Queens
um that I was hoping to close this month
but the contingency is there's a garage
spot that the owner of this Co-op has
that he needs to sell to somebody else
in the building and I do not want it for
the price that he's asking so this is
going to drag out it seems for at least
another
few months if not you know half a year
so if I go and start looking for jobs
now and potentially receive an offer and
I'm looking to make a move that might
affect my mortgage lending ability
because of your change in income
well potentially
that doesn't matter Nick
you can always buy a co-op or or I would
not make a decision
about a co-op I would make the decision
about my life and this work situation is
much bigger than the co-op situation
this is about your livelihood your life
the way you live it you're having a hard
time getting out of bed so I would the
job decision is the one that I'm focused
on not the co-op
what are you making right now Nick
uh so my income varies a little bit
because I'm in sales but I the average
of the past three years is about 140
Grand and you don't think you could make
140 Grand in Tech sales at a different
company
no I definitely think I could
um it's just a matter of I'm scared to
make a jump because I don't want it to
negatively affect the mortgage process
on this Co-op and have this fall through
because I think it's a big opportunity
financially for me
finally own something and and have an
asset
um and I'm young and I'm trying to get
into the real estate game I'm not really
passionate about sex sales I make a lot
of money doing it but I'm really not
um stimulated by it the way that I would
like to are you going to live in this
Co-op
yes okay do you have any debt
no doubt okay
well what's the worst case scenario here
let's say the deal the mortgage doesn't
get approved because you have this
change in income or whatever what
happens
it goes on the co-op and I'm stuck
living in live in a very small apartment
right now in the basement of one of my
dad's rental properties uh The Price is
Right I'm living for free I've been
living here for about 10 or 11 months
the initial plan was only to live here
for a couple until I could close on
something that's a sweet deal in New
York well do you lose any money if you
back out of this deal because of the
mortgage falling through
some couple thousand bucks but nothing
crazy okay so this doesn't it's not
gonna tank your life it would stink
because you're really excited about this
but I'm with Canon I don't want to stick
in this job I hate for six months just
because of this Co-op deal yeah so I
would find another tech sales job if
that's what you need right now
eventually I think you need a whole new
career at least in a better environment
just to get stable just to get stable
then we can figure out what's next and
what career is right for you
thanks for the call hang in there better
days are ahead this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number Ryan joins us now at
San Jose California Ryan how can we help
hi good afternoon guys
um I'm in fifty thousand dollars in
student debt and I grab and I've been
looking for a job but no one has hired
me what are the next steps I should do
well you just keep going you don't quit
so what have you been trying to get
hired to do
so I graduated from University 18 months
ago and when I first graduate I I go
under my Excel spreadsheet type in like
all the students that went in and then
I'm just like okay first goal I'm gonna
go try to seek a job and then that was
from January of 2022 till now it's been
18 months been applying for jobs been on
active on LinkedIn zip recruiter indeed
been applying for jobs no one calls me
for interviews okay and all right either
that or have been ghosted and then I'm
just like initially I was thinking like
okay if there's student loan forgiveness
was to happen twenty thousand might be
forgiven yeah but if not I need to be
serious about this plan what should I do
before I make my first payment in
October yeah all right so Ryan uh
there's gonna I'm gonna give you two
pieces of advice here I want George to
weigh in as well
um
you should have been working the entire
time it was it is it the job that you've
been trying to get probably not I don't
know if it was attached to your major I
never got an answer from you as to what
type of jobs you're looking for we'll
get to that in a minute but you need to
be working we are in a fantastic gig
economy now if you've not heard that
phrase that just means we live in an
economy where you can work whether
you're driving delivery from one of the
major Rideshare companies
or you're doing something locally or
you're doing freelance work the gig
economy is I'm a private contractor
essentially I set my own hours I come
and go and there is a lot of opportunity
in our economy for those type of jobs
they're also right now we're seeing a
tremendous amount of of jobs that are
available in the 15 to 20 an hour range
maybe doing something menial maybe not
doing something that you want to do
but it is money nonetheless and you've
been sitting on the sidelines waiting
for someone
to discover you I've been doing rights
from the side I've been doing right here
on this time all you didn't tell us that
is that how you've been paying the bills
for the last 16 months
correct I've been uh paying the bills
for the last how much money are you
making any rent
uh per week uh per weekend I am work
making between 500 to 600 what are you
doing during the week
during the week I'm just waking up by
nine and then just keep on looking at my
laptop and just applying for jobs Ryan
until someone reaches out to me and
interviews me right that's not enough
you need to be working full time you
need to be working 40 hours a week and
knocking out that debt
you you could have knocked a huge chunk
of that debt out working 40 hours a week
a retail job but whatever it is what
you're doing right now is not working
and you are essentially playing the the
professional Lottery by going on
LinkedIn and sending out messages
sending out resumes and you are a
nameless faceless person and I hate that
for you but that's the process we live
in right now where everything's Ai and
if you apply for a job if you don't have
a relationship connection
to that company
to say hey let me tell you about Ryan I
know Ryan I've known Ryan since he was a
baby or blah blah blah blah blah
whatever it is you've got to make real
personal connections at these at these
companies to get yourself an interview
you're not even getting to the interview
phase and then when you are getting
there nothing's happening because you
haven't stood out prior to the process
or in the game so I'm going to give you
some free resources I'm also going to
give you a couple of paid resources
towards the end I'll tell you what those
are but but you you need to understand
that right now your goal is is you got
to get out of the dull drums you got to
get out of this rut where you're just
sitting around getting rejected day in
and day out hearing nothing but crickets
and only doing Rideshare on the weekend
you could be paying off this this
student loan debt George how much could
he I mean you know the numbers crunch
the numbers how much could he be paying
off uh every month how much could he
have paid off if he's working full-time
while he's trying to find that that that
that placement in the field he wants to
be in well a lot of these as you know
these Rideshare jobs you can easily make
20 bucks an hour delivering food
groceries people packages and so let's
even call that 20 bucks an hour 40 hours
a week that's 800 bucks a week so you
start multiplying that out you said you
don't pay rent right
no I don't pay rent so you're talking
over three grand a month that could have
been going towards paying off these
student loans during the pause so that
you're not on this predicament where now
student loan payments are coming back
and you still are unemployed
so I would get to work ASAP even if it's
not the dream job you could almost be
out of the fifty thousand dollars of
debt is what we're getting at you could
be very close to have paid that off
just doing what George did with those
numbers so what field are you trying to
get into
so I've been trying to be a data analyst
or a financial analyst because I have
more into data analytics and graduate
Finance okay so you got the degree you
had a good GPA all that stuff
correct sir all right so you realize
that you're gonna have to make some
personal connections you got to have
some people calling people on your
behalf that you've already played it the
way that most people try to play it and
then they get they get discouraged
so I'm going to give you a book called
The Proximity principle all right and I
want you to read it or I'll give you the
audio version if that's your preference
and it's a deep dive on how to make
connections because the right people
Ryan plus the right places bring me
opportunity they show up at your door do
you understand that formula
yes sir yeah when I'm around the right
people they'll make good connections for
me when I'm in the right places I meet
more of the right people and I start
getting opportunities you got to get
really serious about this but you're
going to cut your time that you've just
been sitting there submitting resumes
and all that and you're going to get
busy and you're gonna get some momentum
and paying off this debt and uh and then
you from there you're gonna feel a
little bit more juice because you're not
just sitting there looking at that
student loan payment come in and nothing
happening you need some wins right now
and paying off that student loan by
working 40 50 maybe 60 hours a week for
a while would be great and then Making
Connections you're driving and when
you're not driving you're meeting with
people George that's the play and with
no rent I mean let's knock this thing
out while you have that sweet deal
happening yeah so hang on the line we'll
get you a copy of the proximity
principle it'll help you there all right
let's go to Madison Wisconsin where
Clint joins us Clint how can we help
how are you doing guys great how are you
sir
oh pretty good um so me and my wife were
about sixty thousand dollars in debt and
just are struggling to get anywhere
we've been paying on it and it just
seems like we're stuck
what's your income
uh about 90 to 100 a year okay and what
kind of debt is the 60.
uh so there's about 22 in credit cards
there's about 30
say about 34 in car loans and
um yeah I think that's about it and what
is your other car worth
you have two
um yeah sorry yeah sorry
um the other one we owe I think uh
16 on it okay so we got two cars so we
got if I'm looking at this what are
those cars worth you owe 34 and you owe
16 what are both of those cars worth
uh 32 000 in the uh other car is worth
like 40 something I think like 45.
I am selling these cars the cars are
what's crushing you guys I mean this is
way over half your income in the car's
values right and uh the nice thing about
car loans the only nice thing is that
you can kind of undo some of this
especially if the car is worth more than
what you owe and so what if we sold
these cars and you netted out of this
deal you'd net let's see
you probably walk away with at least 20
grand right you could buy two cheaper
cars
right so you buy two cheaper cars that
are 10 grand each for now we'll upgrade
later to something reasonable with cash
that leaves you with the credit card
debt because that high interest is
killing you guys and let's just knock
this stuff out you're making 100K you
got cars that are reasonable you're down
to 22k instead of 60 and let's debt
snowball this thing smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate knock
this out get on a budget get on a proven
plan cut all the discretionary spending
let's try to make more right now for a
season and you'll be out of this thing
within months but if you hang on these
cars there's just gonna be a wait should
we get them in FPU I think we should
let's hook them up with Financial Peace
University feels tired and he feels like
he doesn't have a lot of Hope and we're
going to get you hope with community so
hang on the line we'll get you an FPU
get you and your wife in there and you
guys you're gonna change your life I
know you are we believe in you Clint
thank you so much for the call
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show thrilled
to have you with us I'm Ken Coleman
joined by George Campbell the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five helping you win in
your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
Diana who joins us in Houston Texas
Diana how can we help
hi good afternoon Shannon and George so
my question is when will it be a good
time for us to refinance our home
what's making you want to refinance
well for starters we
um we are paying a five percent interest
um 14 you know for the past 14 years
and we have not we are we still owe
about a little over a hundred thousand
dollars on our principal balance
um we have two daughters um one of them
is about to go to college within a year
and a half from now the other one is not
that far from there so I want to free up
money to start um saving up for college
um also start ramping up on our
retirement fund and just you know having
more cash
um available for us you know are you
wanting to do a Cash out refinance not
just a refinance
well I don't know will make more sense
because you know right now I call my
mortgage company yesterday and
um I was just getting information and
they told me they gave me a interest
rate of a 6.5 Which is higher than what
we're paying right now so
um I just want to get you know
to see will be a good um good decision
should we just continue paying the house
that we are and just making extra
payment towards the principal
um or should we refinance so that's what
I'm calling yeah I don't refinancing is
not going to solve any problems for you
right now and right now is one of the
worst times to refinance because you
guys have a lower interest rate than the
market so that's not the solution to
your problems I would absolutely not do
a Cash out refinance because that's
putting you further into debt and so you
think it may be solving one problem over
here but you're just adding more to the
other side in the pile so the only time
it would make sense to refinance is if
you can get a lower interest rate if you
can move from a variable rate to a fixed
rate which I assume you guys have a
fixed rate right now correct okay you
can get a shorter loan term so if you're
refinancing from a 30 to a 15 year and
you could kind of Roi on that because
you're going to pay closing costs it's
going to cost money to this refinance
you want to make sure that it actually
makes Financial sense
right right so it doesn't sound like
it's going to solve any of that for you
it may just be that the mortgage is just
too much for you guys based on your
income is that the case
well no well uh right now um we're um
our income is between 80 to 100
000 um net depending on you know
um on what my husband does and so forth
but you know I just you know why what's
the mortgage
um right now like what we pay a month
um it's about a little over fourteen
hundred okay a month so the mortgage is
reasonable and that tells me that the
mortgage isn't the problem are there
other expenses that are holding you guys
back from being able to save up for
college do you have any other debt other
than the mortgage no we don't no the
mortgage is it okay so if you're taking
you're telling me you're taking home
anywhere from uh six and a half you know
sixty five hundred bucks to eight
thousand bucks a month
we're in the transportation industry so
um sometimes you know we've been a
couple of years that we have a fairly
good
um you know uh income there are other
couple years where we get kind of low so
that's basically on you know on average
um the sometimes we have made down to 60
maybe 50 a year so it all depends so
hopefully you know
um you know it'll be better
um like we are projecting maybe this
year at about 80. so 82 or 90 so and you
said that's take home pay that's net
income correct yeah okay that's 6 500 a
month let's say call it six for even
numbers 1400 bucks is reasonable that
puts you right at about 25 of your
take-home pay for the mortgage and so I
say all that to say the home is not the
issue we've got to look at uh we can
increase income that's one way we can
save up for college otherwise to
decrease other expenses and so so we got
to look at the budget and go where in
the budget are we missing something how
can we lower our insurance rates by
shopping around with our friends at
Xander are there other discretionary
expenses are we eating out too much do
we have too many subscriptions do we
need to cut the expensive gym membership
those kinds of things as you add them
all up can add up to big numbers to help
you guys save so are you investing right
now in retirement we're
what percentage of your income
um at this time we are not we stopped
last year we as I have about 150 and Ira
um why'd you stop well
okay
they were coveted started you know when
kova started um we my husband didn't
work for a couple of months so when he
when everything started opening up that
was three years ago
right right so
um it could be you know I would say
expenses even though we don't have any
debt but expenses
um that we I think you guys aren't doing
a detailed monthly budget right now and
the money is just floating away and we
need to get back on track so I'm gonna
help you with that I'm gonna gift you
one year of every dollar of the premium
version uh to really make a plan you lay
out that 6 500 bucks at the top and you
are the boss of that budget and once you
make the budget the budget is the boss
of you guys and that will free you to go
oh that's where our money's going we
said we were going to spend 500 bucks on
food it ended up being a thousand
because we got a little lazy so if you
add all that stuff up in the budget it
will allow you to go we gotta invest
fifteen percent of our income to
retirement first whatever's left on top
of that we're gonna start throwing at
College whatever's left over that we're
gonna throw at the house and if it turns
out there's not enough money we got to
increase our income and find some more
stability yeah so hang on the line will
gift you every dollar premium and for
those of you listening out there we have
an amazing deal right now if you go to
every dollar dot com slash George 14 day
free trial and 15 bucks off
15 bucks off uh if you want to get the
premium version so hang on the line
we'll get you that let's go to let's see
Ali in Washington DC
how can we help
hi George and Ken uh thank you so much
for taking my call sure my question is
um on student loans whether I should pay
it all off
or whether I should pay any lonesome
aren't those the same thing
um so I owe a total about 60 54. I do
have enough cash on hand to pay it all
off
um but then like I'm a little bit
nervous about not having enough money
for down payment uh next year
so that that's part of it and then the
other part is we were just thinking
about maybe perhaps a 40K on the student
loan and then like
um taken to next year perhaps like in
two years completely paid off okay well
in the Ramsay plan the way that will
help you do this with peace is to slow
down on the home ownership goal because
right now we got a pile of debt to clean
up so I would not go into Home Ownership
with the student loan still hanging
around my neck
and if that means it slows down the home
ownership process by a year because we
have to save back up I'm okay with that
but right now that money that's Sally
May it's got Sally May's name on it not
your new home name on it and so I would
pay it off in full today let's see where
we're at let's then get an emergency
fund in place of three to six months
then begin saving up that down payment
how long would that take you if you did
it that way
um
um I think I could get it done by the
end of next year I would have more than
enough for for a down payment a nice
down payment for the house and then of
course emergency from nothing I already
have now imagine the amount it sinks it
stinks because you're like man I want to
get a house sooner than that but a year
and a half from now you step into Home
Ownership with no debt except for this
mortgage that's reasonable you step in
with a fully funded emergency fund ready
to cover you because home ownership is
freaking expensive and then you also
have the down payment instead of trying
to put nothing down to scrape by to get
into the home so that's the way to do it
and if you do a 15-year fixed rate with
the payments no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay even though it's
going to take longer I understand that
you will walk into this with a whole lot
more peace yeah and that's what we want
for you and Ali you've been disciplined
to save that money to be able to pay off
these loans you now know that Uncle
Joe's not coming through so pay it off
it's a game changer you're going to be
so much further ahead don't look at it
as I'm behind in my homeowner goal look
at as I'm ahead in life because that's
really what's going on I'd pay them off
now today like before close of business
that'll be a fantastic fantastic way to
sleep tonight thank you for the call all
right don't move more calls coming up
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George Campbell
thrilled to have you with us our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
24 16 for the righteous fall seven times
and rises again but the wicked stumble
in times of Calamity our quote from
Michael Jordan I failed over and over
again in my life and that is why I
succeed
so that's fun so during the commercial
break just to get a little inside
baseball
George and I or any of the Ramsey
personalities twice an hour we go out we
meet folks in the lobby and say hi high
five sign books take pictures and all
this stuff and uh so in hour one today
we had a fine young lady just had her
act together good questions her name was
Jessica she's she was from in Nashville
so we said this is in our backyard and
so as we were talking to Jessica uh I
asked her what point what does she do
what does she do and she works for for
uh crumble corporate training and
corporate training yeah
and I just made a little smart alec
comment well the first thing you need to
do is drop a box of cookies by sometime
and she said as I recall playfully I can
make that happen well so here we are in
hour three and we go out in the lobby to
say hi to some folks and who is in the
lobby with her dad Jessica with a giant
box with a giant box of crumbles I think
that thing is bigger than me it's huge
so we have it on air if you're watching
on YouTube I brought it oh my gosh can
you reveal that to the camera again is
there a way to do that I'm afraid I'm
gonna dump it can we don't dump it is
what Kelly's do not dump it where's her
that's precious cargo there's the camera
I can do I'm very nervous this is like
crumble is not a sponsor they're not an
Advertiser or we just thought it was
really fun it's not an advertising spot
one but people bring us good food I'm
gonna thank them that's really kind of
Jessica so Jessica you're amazing she's
out in the lobby and she has her act
together and she's great and she's
leaving at four in the morning
to go on a training trip so she's
getting after it so well and the
listeners out she wrote us a nice card
the way to Ken's heart is through food
he will accept it if you bring it yeah I
got no problem people ask me all the
time will you eat it I go absolutely we
could eat it what do I don't need an
official taster she did say we have to
share with the team so we're gonna share
it with the team by the way they're very
excited look at him they have been
paying attention for three hours and now
they're jumping up the best part of
their day they're so excited so this is
for the team because they're the ones
that deserve it anyway but here we go
that's right let's go to Vancouver you
ever been to Vancouver I haven't I've
been in Montreal in Quebec but not
Vancouver I'd really like to go uh look
at me now now see I'm getting free
cookies now I'm looking for a free trip
what is Make It Stop George I gotta stop
Brandon can you send Ken to Vancouver
can you make it happen Brandon you're on
the Ramsey Show how's it going hey guys
good thanks for taking my call today
um so I'm fairly new I've been about
three weeks new to this whole Ramsay
show that stuff to work on and it came
at a perfect time because I have a
mountain of debt and uh just wondering
what the fastest way to pay it off would
be it's about a total of 850 000 and
that's including mortgages okay lay them
out for me with the Consumer Debt first
okay Consumer Debt first so I've got uh
4 000 on an loc I've got a MasterCard
with twenty four thousand uh a car with
000 a truck with seventy seven thousand
um and then we've got my personal house
which has got a mortgage remaining of
550 000 and then a rental house with a
remaining mortgage of 170
000 plus a HELOC on my personal house
which is about a hundred and ninety
thousand holy goodness you've been
collecting this stuff man
what is your income and not too proud
about it uh my household income is about
160 to 170 000. okay
what is the truck for
vehicle that we bought it's me and my
wife we have five children and we wanted
something to be able to pull a trailer
to take our family on vacation
do you have an RV
uh no we actually pull my parents um
27-foot trailer to go camping up in New
York okay
it's time to buy some tents I think for
now we vacation in our home yeah because
we are in the backyard broke I think
this truck needs to go that's staring me
down in a bad way and because you can
sell this stuff I'd probably sell the
truck in the car just to help clean some
of this up to give you guys some
breathing room
but what you do here's what you do
ignore the mortgage parts for now let's
focus on this Consumer Debt and lay them
out smallest to largest that makes it
palatable right if you go how quickly
can you pay off this 4K and LLC debt
um we just wrote actually our thing up
last night on our plan and we're hoping
to have that paid off by the end of
August okay so end of August we knock
out the first debt what's the next
biggest step the credit cards uh if we
sell the car
car is 21 the MasterCard is 24. okay
now my my personal plan because I can't
breathe right now is to just sell these
vehicles and just drive beaters for now
even if they're two ten thousand dollar
cars we're not going on vacation we're
broke so we can't afford that anyways
we're not Towing any trailers anytime
soon what if we cleaned up the car debt
that alleviates a hundred thousand of
this Consumer Debt
now you just have credit cards in front
of you for Consumer Debt then we're at
the mortgages you see how that just
speeded a sped up that process
yeah no absolutely our truck
unfortunately a month after we bought it
we actually got hit and it's been now
had to be fixed it had about twenty
thousand dollars in damage a month after
we bought it so I've thought about
selling that but from what I've heard
from I was talking with an insurance
adjuster they figure it's only worth the
price has dropped about 30 to 40 percent
based on that accident what we could get
for it so we'd still be left with like
20 to 25 000 remaining on that even
after you fix it up
well it's already been fixed we've had
it for a little over a year now but it's
already it's depreciated the value
because of the accident
exactly yes
well you said your income was how much
one 140 160.60 to 170 161.70 is there a
way to increase that
I'm I'm already working overtime now my
wife's also starting to pick up some
overtime to help
um bring that up as well okay well
there's no easy shortcut way out of this
and there's no amount of debt you can
move around to make this go away the
only way to make go away is aggressively
pay it off with the debt snowball
smallest to largest increase the income
decrease the expenses find as much
margin as you can to throw at that
smallest debt and just work your way at
this thing and I'd probably sell the
rental what's the rental absolutely
around three hundred thousand so you can
net about a hundred plus to throw at the
other debt
yeah and that would that we've actually
I know this is terrible thinking on my
part looking back now but we've used our
home equity line of credit to purchase
our rental house and it had a slew of
repairs to the extent of about seventy
thousand dollars more than what we were
expecting and that's where we have our
HELOC from
okay but you can still sell the rental
yes that's a game changer you have to do
that it gives you a pretty big momentum
to get this thing started now there's
still a lot of work to do but that'll
help and even being underwater on that
car on that truck I'd probably sell a
rental and use that to cover the
underwater portion yep sell the car get
two beater cars that at least cleans up
a whole lot of this debt that leaves you
with the LLC the credit cards and the
HELOC and then save the mortgage till
the very end
okay what's what is the house worth
um my personal residence yes
about a million dollars okay
now I don't think you need to sell the
house unless this mortgage payment is
killing you guys is it a big part of
your monthly take-home pay
uh it's it's right around that quarter
per Mark it's about uh 2500 a month okay
and you're bringing in 10k but it's
approximately 10. okay yeah so I didn't
think the mortgage was the problem and I
would just say that to the very end I'm
not a huge fan of just using that as the
first shortcut to just sell the house to
get out of this thing I want to see some
Behavior change otherwise you're going
to be right back in this mess a year
from now
and that means the sacrifices of paying
off the truck that we use for the family
vacations and the car and we've got to
stop looking for shortcuts and I feel
like you're ready for that
yeah is yours is your spouse on board as
well
I've been with playing two guys podcast
religiously for the last three weeks
um and she's not quite on board but
she's definitely more on board now that
we've kind of put it out on paper kind
of a plan on what I I was planning on
doing
um but I figured to call you guys I
think I think she'll be able to come on
board with it might be a little bit of a
struggle but if you just the
conversation show her these numbers on
paper show her the interest show her how
long it's going to take to crawl out of
this thing she's going to be willing to
sell some stuff yeah I agree I can't
breathe looking at this stuff man I'm
pulling for you to get out of this thing
call us back if we can help in any way
you imagine just looking at the budget
once all those things are paid off that
we just talked about by the one part
sale of the house that's a game changer
and that's that'll get somebody on board
show them real numbers good hour George
you're gonna need a massage after
walking through that last call maybe a
chiropractor I don't know big thanks
Kelly Daniel for keeping it on the
tracks and the crew in there with her
and then also you America this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]